we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail that came in yesterday
but hey david I was wondering if you
think that the trend towards you know
more autumn autumn Atty z'd warfare what
using drones and stuff like that isn't a
net benefit over you know the
traditional method of just going and
doing on-the-ground warfare I guess
there's a sense but yeah there's a
disconnect that comes from using drones
but at the same time I guess it does
save more a lot more American lives what
do you think about that one in terms of
the pros and cons
yeah well listen you're absolutely right
this is a really important topic you're
absolutely right that drone warfare
saves American lives that's absolutely
true because Americans are able now to
go and carry out a military operation
with no boots on the ground and not even
with pilots in the air right just with
literally remote-controlled aerial
vehicles controlled by a pilot sitting
in front of a computer somewhere so that
certainly reduces the death toll of some
of these operations for Americans we are
told by the advocates of drone warfare
that it also reduces the death toll for
our enemies because the precision of
some of these drones allow the American
military to strike only their intended
target and to reduce collateral damage
and civilian deaths how true that is I
definitely have a question about the the
real problem with drone warfare is sort
of a psychological one and the
disconnect that exists because if you
are boots on the ground
you could still carry out actions that
are humanitarian in nature you could
carry out actions that are totally
deplorable in nature but you have a
completely different connection to what
it is that you're doing then if you are
sitting somewhere in the United States
or on an army base in Germany or
wherever the case may be piloting what
effectively is a remote-control airplane
and the sort of technology zation I know
that's not
word but the technologized of warfare in
these ways I think is very very
problematic in terms of how it might
influence what standards and practices
we use to determine when we are going to
do something and when we are not going
to do something and of course that
doesn't mean there aren't rules of
engagement it doesn't mean that there
aren't legal mechanisms that that are
sort of overriding and controlling a lot
of what it is that's going on here so to
get back to the initial question because
that's really what I want to get to and
your question was in the net do I think
that drone warfare is a benefit or not I
think that if you're thinking in very
concrete short term style you can say
fewer people are probably dying when we
use drones as opposed to other forms of
military incursion the long term answer
may be a very different one where we are
seeing a continued sort of devaluing of
the lives of those populations that we
are targeting and in total the existence
of drone warfare also might make it
possible to carry out way more
incursions in geographically disparate
areas so I think that in the short term
fewer people are dying over the long
term I'm not at all convinced that this
is a positive development but it's
something we've done interviews around
before and that I certainly plan to
continue covering on the bonus show
today we will talk about the teachers
strike across Oklahoma based around
compensation and wages I'm going to talk
about a trump official asking Congress
to start raining in a consumer watchdog
agency no surprise at all that that's
going on and also Grindr the gay dating
app has decided to stop sharing HIV
status to third-party vendors
third-party vendors vendors and
advertisers used to be able to actually
target ads to users of the platform that
disclose their potentially hiv-positive
status which of course would be relevant
in the dating sphere but also would make
them potential targets for particular
products and services and Grindr has
decided they're no longer going to allow
they're third-party vendors to have
access to that information we will be
talking about that and much more on
today's bonus show which you can get
access to by signing up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership we
do have a 40% off coupon code that you
can take advantage of it is vote soon 18
and you can also make a pledge on
patreon to get access to the bonus show
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
thanks for watching today we'll talk to
you then